ALICIA WILLIAMS: Today,
we're talking about I/O,
returning to the office with
Chrome, and a few AI updates.
I'm Alicia, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
We've all been working
from home for a while now.
And as we get back
to the office,
Chrome OS will help us make
that a seamless transition.
At Google, we'll be moving
to a hybrid workweek
where most Googlers spend
approximately three days
in the office and two days
wherever they work best.
It's no surprise that as the
modern secure cloud-first
platform, Chrome OS is playing
a key role in our transition
to a hybrid work model.
Because Chrome OS devices
can easily be shared,
more flexible working models
and spaces are now possible.
We're excited to
announce that we've
made contacts in
our AI even stronger
with Agent Assist for chat,
now in public preview.
Agent Assist provides
your human agents
with continuous support
during their calls,
and now chats, by identifying
the customer's intent
and providing them with
real time recommendations,
such as articles and
FAQs, as well as responses
to customer messages to
more effectively resolve
the conversation.
PyTorch is an open source
machine learning and deep
learning library
predominantly used in research
and has gained tremendous
traction in the industry
as well due to its ease
of use and deployment.
Google Cloud AI platform
is a fully managed
end-to-end platform for data
science and machine learning
on Google Cloud.
In this new series of blog
posts, PyTorch on Google Cloud,
we aim to share how to
build, train, and deploy
PyTorch models at
scale and how to create
reproducible machine learning
pipelines on Google Cloud.
I/O was last week.
And if you missed
the virtual event,
be sure to check out
the technical talks
on your favorite
product YouTube pages.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.